[Music]
[Applause]
there are still lots of amazing moments
coming up in the show we've got more
performances and of course the game of
the Year announcement uh-oh whoa what's
going on okay Joker I've infiltrated the
theater wait seriously he went alone to
the but it's so far wait why is he there
there's only one thing the Phantom feeds
apart specialize in these they had to
steal a treasure have you already sent a
calling card we're not the ones sending
a card this time in fact we've been
invited invited to steal the greatest
treasure of all
[Music]
we'll be going up against the best of
the best can't wait to see our fearless
leaders show his death
persona
I am thou thou art I show the strength
of thy will and rage against all
challengers
[Music]
Oh Reggie Reggie rich we meet again
quite the surprise so all right so Super
Smash Brothers coming out tonight but it
looks like I know a great choice of
shirt here Reggie the internet is going
crazy the announcement of Joker persona
5 coming to Smash Brothers everyone's in
this game everyone's in this game right
so we've said that Super Smash Brothers
ultimate it is the biggest crossover in
videogame history
dare I say the biggest crossover in
entertainment yo brothers might have
some and and so and so yes you know the
the the games about to launch were super
excited were super excited to give the
fans the opportunity to summon or
persona
into the game amazing all right so then
you said challenger pack 1 so these are
the the DLC fighters that will come out
correct
yeah and so this gives you a flavor of
how we're approaching the DLC so the DLC
there's going to be 5 characters each
character will come with a stage it'll
come with a collection of music these
are going to be characters that are new
to the series just like Joker from
persona 5 characters that you would not
anticipate to be in Super Smash Brothers
ultimate we're super excited about this
the fans can go and they could get their
fighters pass to get all of the five
fighters that will be coming to the
series we're tremendously excited well I
would think you'd be even more excited
because tonight smash is about to launch
right smash is about to launch and
you can you know you needed to have a
really good show for me to be here
versus you've been through your
presentation sure everything's going
great for the launch yeah we're super
excited
smash is just minutes away yes and it's
gonna be fantastic
all right well Reggie you've been here
every year for us for the game where
it's really appreciated and before we go
maybe we should head to the stage for
the game awards Orchestra a little
something for Super Smash Brothers
Reggie great to see you enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]